you said he talked about magic and what
domesticated zombies delirious people
will say anything whoa this looks like a
way out we are running out of fantasy we
have to explore every possibility hi I'm
Kate and this is Lucy and Lucy you've
just been to Poland to check out dying
light tell us about that so I saw the
dynamic following which is the new
expansion it's coming out as part of the
expansion price if you buy it on its own
and it's also part of dime an enhanced
edition I sat down with it for maybe
like four or five hours I played a good
chunk of it it was I killed a lot so
what's new about daylight the following
so it is if you if you played the base
game of dying light you are a parkour
guy Kyle crane a great name running
around the city of Harran basically
running errands for people park going
around killing zombies crafting new
crazy weapons all of that is still in it
but instead of being in a dense
cityscape you're in a lovely farm kind
of area so it really changes the way you
play because especially one way is that
guns are much more of a thing if you
used guns and dying light and you in the
city you'd kind of be screwed because
zombie smaller would come here you you'd
get boxed into a corner couldn't really
shoot your way out because of limited
ammo that's kind of all changed because
in the farm you can there's a lot more
human enemies but you can also take out
zombies and not be afraid of being
swarmed because this fields to just run
around it and what can you talk about
the story without spoiling it too much
it's this guy and he's been bitten but
he's not turning and he you know makes
these veiled references this person for
the mother and this weird cult so Kyle
crane managed to find his way out of the
city of her on and find these people
these followers and basically he's
trying to figure out how they aren't
succumbing
and becoming zombies but the thing is
learn from is they don't care about you
they will not listen to you or talk to
you tell you anything so you have to do
a bunch of stuff for them basically
which is what you're doing this
beginning of the game you know you're
clearing out bandits you're rescuing
people and the more you do that the more
you build up your follower rank
which is kind of a new skill tree and
the more that people will talk to you
listen to you get more missions okay so
how long do you think you'd be playing
the game for if you did everything you'd
be playing
I mean Dinah itself is a big game and
this map in the following is as big as
the main game map so if you did
everything there's a bunch of SciQuest
the stuff doing co-op there's a ton of
end level content as well so if you max
out all your skill trees there's a new
thing called legends rank let's know you
rank and you can go up to legend level
like 250 all the time you're earning new
skills weapons skins so I mean if you
take that aside if you want to do
everything in DLC I think the dev said
that was you know anywhere between
fifteen to thirty forty hours okay so
what can you tell us about those skill
trees can you mention them a bit as well
okay so you've got your follow rank so
more stuff you do the game the more that
people just want to give you things to
do but there's also a new driving skill
tree which basically works in the same
way as your parkour and your combat one
worked in the main game in that if you
know you drive around you kill zombies
you boost over things in the cool you
use you unlock things so you can unlock
better engine parts better better
suspension turbo nitro you can mod it of
course I mean it's time light you can
want everything in what oil weapons the
bug is no different so you can add a
flamethrower on there you can drop mines
behind you and you can like drop online
behind you sort of nitro out of there
you can also have an electric cage one
of my favorite things to do is so you
have a car alarm so you can set it and
just you know get out of there and all
the zombies get drawn to it and then
what you do is if you think a sufficient
number of surrounding a car you can set
off the electric cage and it just sort
of is this little implosion and it's
just so satisfying to watch you can all
see that while you're driving around so
if you see a big group of them coming up
with him set up the cage and it's like
this EMP pulse that just shot a lorry
so would you say the buggy is Opie
definitely not at the beginning so at
the beginning especially there's a real
risk reward with it because first of all
you run out of fuel signal if you hit
too many zombies in one go stuff gets
damaged and things can break and it just
won't handle as well which is really
difficult when you're being chased by
stuff and so in order to do that you
have to scavenge it's another great bit
of dying lies that you have to look for
everything pick up everything and you
also have to scavenge for fuel which is
also kind of panicky because that's
typically where the zombies like to
congregate is around Park cars and there
any particular moments you had when you
were playing that you really want to
tell us about so I think one of the fun
things for me is the most interest its
new weapon the crossbow and it's very
different because if you approach a farm
say with a bunch of human enemies you
can stealth it which is something that
I'm not really a student dying like so
it's very different men
you can either you have crossbow heads
that make God sick so you can have fire
cloud of gas in them and they'll just
start throwing up a lot work some
zombies too the crossbow is really
powerful and it's just it's really fun
it's a really different way to play as
well so it's sort of like you're not
gonna get bored and also it's nice to be
able to use the gun play mode because
the guns were fun in the main game but
you will always never you never really
want to using now it's it's really
satisfying and just cool so if you could
describe dying light the following in
one sentence or you go for it's just
really fun it's a it's a it's a game
that's mixed together things like
parkour gunplay driving really really
well and it's just really satisfying
just to you know just bond down a road
and drive through zombies and
it's really sounds like three senses to
know all right one sentence three fun
loved it
so there you go dying light the
following it's really fun box quote die
later following is coming out on
February 9th and for all your zombie
updates keep it GameSpot